should people run a business first
before they start making films so I'm
gonna take us off on a little tangent
but there's a book called the long tail
by Chris Anderson Chris Anderson up
until recently was the editor-in-chief
of Wired magazine is one of my heroes
has both the long tail is a best-seller
and it basically is the idea that there
is very soon because of the internet and
distribution channels of changing going
to be as much money to be made in the
tail of a market as in the head which
means that traditionally Hollywood
blockbuster movies made all the money
that's the head and then the tail of the
market which is everything else made up
less than 10% of the amount of money
made and this meant that independent
films and things like that fell into
that less than 10% and didn't do very
well but because of different marketing
strategies and Netflix and things like
that the tail is starting to raise and
the head is starting to lower in the
amount of money they're making so
they're gonna equal out to be a flatline
eventually distribution is completely
democratized and that means that
independent filmmakers can make start to
make real money doing this not as much
money as Hollywood makes but more than
they make working for Starbucks for
instance and that is something that we
would very much like to see not just for
our business but for the market in
general and the variety of movies and
things like that and the quality of
movies in my opinion will go up and but
but one of the things that will need to
happen is that independent filmmakers
will also need to become independent
business people they'll become one in
the same so there's no way to create an
independent market that is self
sufficient without each each body and an
independent market being a
self-sufficient business entity also
I mean I think in some way in order to
have any kind of career you have to see
yourself as a business person even if
you're an artist you know a painter who
doesn't show their work who doesn't
search out to get a gallery to show that
work in you know they're not going to
necessarily be able to support
themselves on their art so to some
degree while it can be a warrant to
people who want to just live a fully
artistic lifestyle independent of any
sort of money management that really is
an important part of creating and
sustaining a career and I think that as
stuff like YouTube you know as the
channel model becomes more and more
popular where people will have control
over their distribution channels it will
become more important for them to be
able to budget things to be able to
deliver on a consistent basis and that's
something that you know I think that
there's such a split right now in terms
some people don't necessarily see
themselves ever being able to make films
on a level that will show theatrically
that you know will be a big deal
you know so felt real or studio
filmmaker and I think that keeps people
from creating a game plan of how they're
going to make money off of their films
and you see this particularly with
shorter micro-budget features but it's
really something that if people can
learn to do and understand it's part of
what it takes to get yourself out there
then that will really help people as we
move into an easy
you